>> Greg: A MASSIVE INVASION OF
PRIVACY COULD BE COMING,
COURTESY OF UNCLE SAM.
A NEW PROPOSAL BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL GIVE THE IRS
ACCESS TO ALL BANK ACCOUNTS WITH
BALANCES OF $600 OR MORE.
REPUBLICANS ARE CALLING IT A BIG
GOVERNMENT INTRUSION GREETED >>
DO YOU DISTRUST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SO MUCH THAT YOU NEED TO
KNOW WHEN THEY BOUGHT A COUCH OR
A COW?
>> THEY WON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
MONEY YOU'VE GOT THE BANK, HOW
MUCH YOU ARE SPENDING, IF YOU
BOUGHT A WEDDING DRESS OR GUN.
THEY WILL HAVE A MATT DOVE MIGHT
LIST A MILE LONG ON YOU.
>> WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH BUILDING BACK BETTER OR
INFRASTRUCTURE, OR EVEN EQUITY?
>> Greg: JESSE, COWS --
COUCHES, IN YOUR CASE, $600 ON
HAIR PRODUCTS IN A WEEK.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE CUSTOMER
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THANKS ALWAYS WIN.
THEY'VE GOT LOBBYISTS DOWN THERE
MAKING SURE THIS DOES NOT GET
IN.
THE BANKS ALWAYS WIN.
BIDEN HAS SOME NERVE AFTER HIS
SON HUNTER IS BEING PROBED FOR
TAX FRAUD, FOR TAKING DIAMONDS
AND HIDING OVERSEAS INCOME, THEN
JOE IS GOING TO GO OFF AND
SLAPPED THE IRS ON EVERY
AMERICAN WITH A BANK ACCOUNT?
YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR BANK
IS SACRED, LIKE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR LAWYER
OR --
'S BEFORE YOUR WIFE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: IT IS A ONE A
ONE-ON-ONE RELATIONSHIP.
>> Dana: HOPEFULLY.
>> Jesse: IT IS NOT A
THREESOME.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE YOU AND
YOUR BANK.
I DON'T TRUST THE IRS, DO YOU?
THEY LEAKED DONALD TRUMP'S
TAXES, THEY LEAKED THE TAXES OF
JEFF BEZOS.
THEY ALWAYS LEAK.
REMEMBER WHAT THEY DID WITH THE
TEA PARTY?
I DON'T TRUST ANY IRS AGENT TO
LOOK INTO MY BANK ACCOUNT.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, IT WILL BE
IN THE "NEW YORK DAILY NEWS."
THAT'S WHERE THEY LINK IT TO
APPEAR THE OTHER THING, IT'S
GOING TO PUSH EVERYBODY OUT OF
THE BANKING SYSTEM AND INTO
PLACES LIKE THIS GOING "IF YOU
ARE AFRAID THE GOVERNMENT IS
SNOOPING ON YOUR CHECKING
ACCOUNT --" THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY PEOPLE HIDE.
I GET IT, BUT NOT REGULAR WAGE
EARNERS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WITH
PARTNERSHIPS AND FAMILY
BUSINESSES, THAT'S WHERE THE
MONEY IS HID IN RE-FINANCING
REAL ESTATE, NOT HERE.
>> Greg: JESSICA, IS THERE
SOMETHING WE ARE MISSING?
IT'S THE STRONG ARGUMENT FOR
THIS, AND WHY $600?
I DON'T GET THIS.
>> Jessica: I WAS SURPRISED TO
SEE JANET YELLEN DEFENDING IT.
$600 IS A LOW -- IT'S NOT THAT I
DON'T VALUE MONEY, BUT THAT IS
AN AMOUNT THAT THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN COULD HAVE IN A SAVINGS
ACCOUNT, AND HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
POWERFUL ARGUMENT THAT DEMOCRATS
MAKE ABOUT THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
FAMILY NOT BEING ABLE TO HANDLE
A MEDICAL EMERGENCY, LIKE WHEN
WE GO INTO ELECTIONS AND SAY
"THIS IS WHY WE NEED BETTER
HEALTH CARE OPTIONS, BETTER
WAGES.
IF SOMETHING, GOD FORBID, WERE
TO HAPPEN TO AN UNINSURED FAMILY
THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO COVER
THE COST."
THAT COST IS HIGHER THAN THE
$600, AND THERE HAS BEEN PUSHED
BACK FROM DEMOCRATS ON IT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
YOU WANT THE RICH PEOPLE, THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING THROUGH
SHELL COMPANIES AND ARE
REPORTING THEIR INCOME, THAT'S
NOT THE AVERAGE PERSON WAS $600,
AND THAT'S $80 BILLION OUT OF
THE BILL THAT WE COULD TAKE OUT.
>> Greg: EMILY, IF YOU COMPARE
THIS TO THE STREETS, THE RANK
RAPID CRIME, ANARCHY ON THE
STREETS, WHICH WE WILL TALK
ABOUT IN THE D BLOCK --
[LAUGHTER]
-- WE ARE TO TOO BUSY GOING
AFTER TAXPAYERS.
WE ARE GOING AFTER PARENTS
GETTING IN FIGHTS AT SCHOOL
BOARDS, GOING AFTER PEOPLE AT
$600, BUT NOT THE PEOPLE
COMMITTING CRIMES.
>> Emily: THIS PRESIDENT KEEPS
VILLAIN EYES IN THE WRONG
AMERICANS.
>> Greg: VILIFYING?
>> Emily: NO, VILLAIN-IZING.
>> IT WOULD BEHOOVE YOU TO SAY
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: I LOOK LIKE A
VILLAIN TODAY.
ON YOUR POINT, THE SPENDING BILL
ALREADY INCLUDES $80 BILLION TO
GO TOWARDS THE IRS SO THEY CAN
HIRE NEW STAFFERS.
THIS RESULTS IN THEM GETTING
BACK $700 BILLION IN THE NEXT 1.
THE IRS ADMITS ITS DATA
IS 7 YEARS OLD, SO THEY ARE
USING YOUR TAX DOLLARS TO PAD
THEIR BUDGET MORE TO HIRE NEW
PEOPLE TO GO AROUND AND TAX
AVERAGE AMERICANS.
WE ARTIE KNOW THAT THE IRS IS
WHERE COMMON SENSE GOES TO DIE.
I WILL GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF THIS BLOATED BUDGET.
I'VE SEEN A $100,000 PROSECUTION
ON THE CRIMINAL SIDE FILLED WITH
SHADY INDIVIDUALS, TO RECLAIM A
$30,000 ALLEGED FRAUD.
YOU SEE ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN THEY
LEAKED THE JEFF BEZOS AND
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG RECORDS, THEY
SAID "TRUST US, WE WILL
INVESTIGATE AND HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE."
WHAT ARE THE RESULT OF THAT?
THEY ARE SIMPLY INVESTIGATING
YOU.
>> Greg: DANA, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Dana: ON THE IRS ISSUE, I
TALKED WITH PEOPLE WHO WORK ON
THE SENATE SIDE.
THIS ISSUE OF THE IRS EXPANSION
THAT BIDEN WANTS TO DO WAS ONE
OF THE TOP THREE ISSUES SENATE
OFFICERS ARE GETTING CALLED
ABOUT.
THEY ARE MAD BECAUSE IT IS A
$97 BILLION -- THEY ARE MAD
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO EAT THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE LOBBYISTS OR
ACCOUNTANTS THAT COULD HELP THEM
NAVIGATE THAT.
THE INTERESTING THING IS THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING, AND
TRUMP REALLY PUSHED THIS --
CUTTING RED TAPE FOR SMALL
BUSINESS.
BIDEN WANTS TO CUT RED TAPE FOR
THE IRS AGENTS AND HIRE MORE OF
THEM SO THEY CAN GO AFTER YOU,
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT:
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS NOMINATED A
WOMAN WHO WOULD BECOME
CONTROLLER OF THE CURRENT -- I
CANNOT BELIEVE THIS.
SHE WENT TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
MOSCOW ON A LENIN SCHOLARSHIP.
SHE HAS SAID THAT THE MARKET
DOES NOT ALWAYS KNOW BEST.
BASICALLY, SHE WOULD BE PUT IN
CHARGE OF THE CURRENCY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I THINK ABOUT THIS AND THE C
TOPIC, AND D BLOCK TOPIC.
YOU ADD ALL THAT TOGETHER.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
A TRIAL SEPARATION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: I BET Y